you've got your guitar it's all tuned up
you know how to practice and how not to
practice now you're finally ready to
play so today I'm going to teach you
what's called the key of G now in order
to have any idea what that means and
actually have some language to describe
this I'm going to teach you some words
first okay I'm three important words the
first word is a note right so no it's
just whenever you play a single string
for instance we call this the E string
right so you're playing the note e there
and if I change the fretting frizzes if
I if I put my finger here on the second
fret I'm now not playing an e anymore
I'm playing an f-sharp
so that's another note right so no it's
are these individual sounds that you can
make on the guitar
okay now when you put together a bunch
of these sounds a bunch of these notes
what you get is a chord right so for
instance if I play this I play well just
now I played five of the strings okay
and they relate in a particular way and
those five strings make up a chord right
so you put together notes you get it
caught you put together the chords and
if you've got different chords some that
fit together nicely kind of like a
family of chords if you like it's called
a key right so generally you've got a
few chords that often get played
together and it sort of sound fit
naturally together there's more you know
there's not an accidental relationship
if you can't study music theory you can
understand exactly why some chords fit
together with others better but I'm not
really worried about that the important
thing to get is that when you get a
whole bunch of chords the main bunch of
coins that repeat through a song for
instance that's the key that those
chords are in is the key of the song and
so often you hear people say oh what key
is that song in can we change the key
bridge ate it up or down and what
they're afraid to is the basic set of
chords that belong in a song okay so the
first key that I'm going to teach you is
the key of G now G is the most natural
key to play a normal standard ly
standardly a guitar is tuned in standard
tuning
which is EAD GBE and the reason why is
because I in the key of G the chords
that you use most of them don't require
you to hold down a whole bunch of
strings long finger which is called a
bar chord right most of them with one
exception now if you play music for
piano there's a similar kind of idea the
easiest key to playing piano is the key
of C because you only need the white
notes you don't need the black notes in
between
okay so in a similar way the guitar is
kind of built for the key of G if you
like you can play all kinds of other
keys but G is the most natural one okay
so I'm going to show you that the chords
that belong in in this key had a plan
and a few different things apart from
that so to start with it makes sense
that the most important chord in the key
of G is the G chord now I should have
mentioned as well it's the key I'm going
to talk about the key of G major and
major Keys major chords rather other
ones that sound happy so for instance
here's an E
that's an E major it sounds happy and
he's an E minor so you've got major and
minor keys and major and minor chords
very very few piece of music are written
in minor keys so that's why instead of
people saying AHS in the key of G major
it's just ordinary to say the key of G
and if it's in a minor chord which is
quite unusual they'll say that instead
so if you hear someone say I songs in
the key of G that's what they mean now
the first chord the key of in the key of
G is the G and by the way all of these
chords have names I'm going to teach you
some of them it's not that important
but sometimes it will help so you can
refer to each other and if you are
changing to a different Creed key you'll
understand which are the important
chords and how they relate to each other
so this is the standard way to play a G
and you can see reading from the top to
the bottom in terms of physical rather
than the top to the bottom in terms of
pitch I have my fingers placed on the
third fret on the e-string
the second fret
on the a-string I leave these three
strings open 1 2 3 and then on the the
highest or who hosts a confusing on this
Easter Egg here I've also got the the
third fret held down okay
so often you'll see that written if
you're trying to learn a chord or a new
chord shape and this is written as 3
we're referring to the 3rd fret 3 2 0 0
0 because I'm not touching those frets
those things and also that's why it's
kind of like you're you're holding down
the 0th fret 3 to 0 0 0 3 and that's a
standard G chord ok now you can see that
that doesn't tell you which fingers you
should use to hold it but most people
who use of their 3 longest fingers index
middle and ring finger to hold them down
it is the easiest way one of the
important things that you need to make
sure that you do is not accidentally
touch other strings so these 1 2 3
strings in here which you're not
touching it's very easy to accidentally
let some of your other fingers not hold
them down but just touch them enough to
stop them playing or or make them buzz
which is not what you want to do so
using your 3 loong whose fingers is the
easiest way to do that
okay so 3 2 0 0 0 3 and using those 3
fingers now it's worth learning the
reason why make a big deal about the
fingers is number one you can choose
whichever fingers you like as long as
it's physically possible but number two
and there's lots of different ways right
and sometimes one way will be more
suitable than another
ok so for instance I actually don't
usually play G with these three fingers
I usually use these 3 okay now why am I
using my little finger because it's so
much shorter why do I do that well
firstly once you get used to it it's
actually not that hard because your your
little finger even though it's short
it's only trying to reach to this bottom
the high E string and so it doesn't have
to reach very fast so it being short is
no big issue for me but more importantly
I'm still holding down three to zero
zeros
but now my index finger is free and so I
can use that to do other things so for
instance this mystery here which is the
B which is the B I can hold it down here
on the first fret and I can play a chord
which is just like this this is the G
without the without the index finger
when I put the index finger there and
this chord is called a G sus for the sus
is short for I'm suspended I think
suspended yeah I'm changing the that
note there for a higher and you often
hear these two chords G sus4
and a G together they kind of have a
nice relationship to each other
the main chord hasn't changed
but just that one note changing is it
number one it's a common change and
number two it's a change that sounds
kind of nice and often gives you a sense
of completeness you know it's like you
have this Jesus porches like a kind of
not quite finished
I'm home okay now a couple of things
this is called the G chord right the
most important thing about it is the
bass note the basement kind of changes
it defines everything which is why when
I when I change that one note up there
it's still mainly a G and it's just that
little bit on the end of the chords name
Jesus for changes because the bass note
which is the deepest node is I'm up here
so this is the e string right as I
change my fretting the note changes so
goes to F to F sharp to G so the
basement of this chord is a G so that's
that's the main reason why along with
all the other notes that are playing
it's a G chord okay all right now I just
tell you one more other way to play the
G chord a very common way which is to
use all four of your fingers okay
so what you're going to do is have your
index and middle fingers up the top here
playing the third fret and the 2nd fret
on those two strings then zero zero and
then instead of having three zero zero
zero zero zero three on these these
strings up here I'm gonna play three
three so this is three two zero zero
three so you played all together it
sounds I've been higher because I'm
playing this B stream three frets higher
than I normally would so this is a
Normandy
and this is the other G that I'm playing
now this this extra change in note has
another name as well but to be honest I
don't know what it is and you don't
really need to know the names of the
chords are not that important as long as
you know what the fingering is okay
now I'll explain a bit later why that's
an that's that extra ring finger is on
that three and why that makes things
easier and a lot of songs have that kind
of arrangement but I'll get to that a
little later now it's the it's the main
chord of the key G so that gives it a
special name it's called the tonic okay
and it's it's the it's the chord you'll
probably hear them most in the song and
it's also the chord where the song feels
at home so if a song is written in the
key of G very frequently the very last
chord or say the chorus or the last
quarter the whole song will be a G
because it's like okay now the song
feels complete it's so that's why it's
often called the home cord
okay so there's the G alright now I'm
going to go through the rest of the
chords in order as well as being called
the tonic it's also called core number
one so it's kind of your starting point
so as you go up it goes one two three
four five six and so often people who
name the chords just on their number
okay and they go up in terms of note so
from G the next one's going to be an a
but it's actually a minor so an a minor
looks like this
now the proper way to plan is to ignore
that eastream
because I don't actually want an e base
it's an a minor so sometimes you'll see
that written as an X or when you're when
I had the G before which is three two
zero zero zero
that means you play or six streets right
but here I you might see next so don't
play that note the actual first note you
play is this though so they'll say zero
because it's um I haven't I'm the hon no
no frets there and that makes it an a so
that's why then a minor has an a bass so
sorry
the rest of the chord of X so don't play
that 0 2 2 1 see now by the way don't
freak out too much about like are
there's so many numbers to keep up with
you can find all of these online really
easily in fact there's this apps that
you can get for this as well which will
teach you what are all the numbers you
should play which is correspond to what
frets you should be holding down so
there's the a minor okay so that's core
number two core number three is the B
minor which is the same shape it's the
same shape but the way that I play it is
take these three fingers so again I'm
using my three million fingers and I'll
rotate them around so instead of using
fingers 1 2 & 3
I'm gonna use fingers 2 3 & 4 so again
I'm gonna go to my my little finger so
I'm gonna play the same notes there
right now that's still anybody right ok
now this is still an a minor because I'm
still holding down the same fret but if
I move this shape up two frets ok so I
went from 0 to 2 1 0 okay I'm gonna move
the 2 2 1 2 B 4 4 3 ok so they go to
there and you'll also be able to see on
probably on the UM on the neck of your
guitar there'll be some dots there and
they help you to be able to see without
without you know pushing you over and
looking at the front of your guitar what
fret you're on so you tend to have dots
at 3 5 7 9 and 12 anyway that's not
important really now in order to make it
a problem B minor you also need this
index finger to 3 this is why we rotated
the fingers around ok and it needs to
hold down all of those strings there now
this sort of needs to hold down all of
them in practice all you really need to
hold
down is the a string there and the the E
string at the bottom of the guitar
because the rest of the strings are
covered either by it you don't need to
play them right or they're covered by
these on the three fingers so this is
what I mean remember the a minor was X 0
2 2 1 0 okay
now when you got to the B minor again is
an X because this there's no here's an
f-sharp well I don't want that F sharp
note in my B minor I just want to go
straight to this that's the B because it
started as an A ok so I've got that be
held down by this speaker and then I've
got 4 4 3 and then the same index finger
is holding that um eastream there okay
so it's my B minor okay now this is a
barre chord okay it's called a bar
because your index finger has to play
some make a bar across all of these
strings and by the chords are yeah
probably I'm just thinking there are
some pretty awful looking chords out
there but Barre chords it generally
agree is the hardest notes to play are
chords to play because you you see you
need some serious strength in that
finger okay so I'll talk about bar
chords another time but that's the only
one in them in the key of G okay now the
next chord I had on G which is the first
chord a minor which is the second chord
B minor which is the third one now we
get to the fourth one which is C okay so
the standard way to play a C is to play
is to go X so don't play that three two
zero one
okay there's a C okay that's a standard
way to player C now I almost never
played my see this way I tend to play
rather than leaving this e string
unplayed I tend to put my ring finger up
there so I'm using all four of my
fingers now so what I play instead is
three three two zero one zero
okay now you remember I said the bass
note the deepest note of the chord is
the the note that kind of defines most
of the chord okay
in this case I'm actually playing a note
deeper than the there's the scene of my
C chord but I'm also playing the G you
might have recognized that from the G
chord so it's the third fret on the E
string there okay so this is actually
not really a sea it's a sea with a G
bass because I'm playing that extra G
okay the reason why I play that is
because G as a note fits into the C
chord a lot better than E which is this
on the top this mystery without without
any Freddie okay so this is a sea with
an e bass if I was actually to play that
which does have its place sometimes but
let's see with a G base if you can tell
the difference I'm not sure if them I
can pick it up it feels a little more
natural a little more hard so that's
that's how I play the see another really
common way if you go back to the G chord
they would play right this is the the
four-fingered version that I was showing
you of the G you can see that if I just
take these two fingers here and move
them down yeah one set of strings okay
I've got the same kind of fingers here
that I had in the the C chord see how
it's matched up by these two fingers now
they're there okay
so when you play that even though these
strings up here are playing what was in
the G chord the G chord C chord overlap
a lot you guys have a very close
relationship to each other which I'll
explain another time so it's still it's
still a say I think it's like I see ad 9
or something like that began the Nathan
important this sounds quite nice it
sounds like this
so I still sounds alright so he was that
earlier gee and here's the scene now
because that change is so easy these two
fingers down here I'm not going anywhere
it's just my index on my middle finger
which are easier to move because they're
stronger more independent you'll often
see those kinds of corn to pair up
together and there's a few other ones
that also go with them so there's three
ways to play the C chord this is the
normal way
ignore that string I'm just playing see
there I tend to add the extra finger and
play of C with a G bass but just as
common you'll see the G the fourth
finger G version and then you move those
two fingers up so this is really three
two zero three three see now the this C
chord I got up to the fourth chord right
it's called the subdominant chord so I
had the tonic at G I had which is the
first chord I have a minor then I had B
minor now I've got C major and it's
called the subdominant chord which the
meaning of that will make sense once I
get to the next chord which is the D
okay so this is a D major here so you're
going to have to play ignore these two
strings up here E and then a because
they're not the bass notes that we want
and they don't fit very nicely with the
D chord so it just starts with that
string there okay so it goes xx 0 3
sorry 2 2 3 2
so I'm actually playing these four
streaks you
zero to three two okay now this sounds
quite hard to master at the beginning
because when you start strumming okay on
your strumming hand if you're
right-handed why which is most of you or
even if your left head and most people
who play right head of guitar because
left-handed guitars are armed rare and
expensive so if you play with your right
hand most people is right here and start
off without the accuracy required to
just play those four strings because
you've got to be quite precise
especially if you have a strong pattern
so this to miss out playing these
strings up here the E and the a yeah it
requires some practice and precision
okay but the thing is the chord doesn't
sound very nice when you do play those
because E and a they don't belong that
much in the D chord it sounds like this
now you can kind of hear the e doesn't
belong that's the main one which is the
problem a is not so big a deal
but having an e based on a D chord
really doesn't fit okay so you've got to
work on what are the things that you're
going to practice is as your strumming
starting at that that fourth string
there and missing the other ones and
that takes some time okay so there's a D
now the D after the tonic the G the the
court in which the key is this called
the fifth chord one two three four is
the most important coin okay after after
the Toni
so that's why this coin is called the
dominant chord it's really really
important okay so that's why this is the
dominant one the C we teachers before it
the fourth chord is the sub-dominant
because it's also really important just
not as important as the fifth chord okay
so G and in the key of G you often see G
and and C played over and over again min
the most important chords in the key
okay
now there's lots of variations on the D
just like with all the other courts so
this is a G sorry this is a deep one of
the most common variations you'll have
just like with G is a dese us for now
where's the where's the extra four come
in it comes in with your little finger
which is out here it needs to hold down
the third fret near on the the high E
string so it sounds like this
and you can see it wants to go back to
the regular D chord okay so that's why
you often hear these together you'll
hear a D and then a decent forward them
back to a D like this or you'll hear it
stay on this us for for a while and then
finish just on a regular D like this and
so you can see those going to get up so
that's the D that's the D sauce another
common one is the D sus 2 or sometimes
just written as D 2 instead of putting
an extra finger down you take your
regular D and you let go of your middle
finger this one which is holding the
high E string on the second fret so you
let go of that make sure that your other
fingers don't overlap and accidentally
mute that string stop it from playing
but it sounds like this
again if it feels like it's not quite
home it doesn't want it wants to go
somewhere namely the regular D chord so
there's the Dietz attitude
and the regular D so you've got D sauce
for dese us too and the regular D they
all three actually often get used
together so you might see or hear rather
things like this not only doesn't sound
nice but it's really easy to play
there's very little movement involved
and the chords are quite easy to hold
down so there are lots of kinds of
variations on there so depending on the
the song you might you might hear it
something like this and you can put them
in any combination really so another
semi common version of the D requires
quite a different fingering it's called
the d7 so instead of 0 2 3 2 I'm gonna
play 0 2 1 2 ok so as you can see it
ones over here so in order to reach
there I can't just let go on this
briefing here and say I can't go over
there
might be just doesn't go right so you've
got to rearrange your fingers entirely
so at the moment I'm going index ring
finger middle finger as I go down the
fret board ok but to play it d7 to reach
that one over there the first fret I
rearranged like this so I've got my
middle finger here then my next we got
then my ring finger and it sounds like
this
you can see that it's got a sort of you
hear often in sort of like country music
so sometimes Taylor Swift uses a d7
5-minute um you can go to a regular D
just by putting your little finger there
there's my regular D okay now I'm gonna
take that shape there the regular D and
you can see now this is like the D I
explained before I've just cycled the
fingers around just like I did with the
the G chord in the first place okay
still a Dean now the reason why you
might do that is because now you have
your index finger free again to hold
down a different string the most common
string that it holds down is a the
f-sharp that so the second fret on on
the bottom E string and that's the reed
the reason why is because even though an
E doesn't fit very well with the D chord
the f-sharp does so you quite often see
this written as R D with an f-sharp bass
I should have mentioned as well the way
they'll actually write that because on
computers you know writing deal with an
f-sharp bass just as a phrase is a long
phrase so often you'll see that written
as d / f-sharp and the shop is that is a
hashtag okay so when you see D slash
f-sharp
that means play a D chord but have the
f-sharp base often you hear that because
the f-sharp wants to go just just up one
semitone to the G so those two chords
often progress together okay so there's
the D so that's quite a number five the
dominant chord what are most important
chords indicate all right now even
though there's a whole bunch of other
calls I can show you the last one that
I'm going to show you is um the sixth
chord so G is a minor 3 B minor C 4 C 5
which is d the 6th chord is a minor E
minor a really nice easy chord to play
you only need to hold down two strings
so you're going to play 0 to 2 and then
0 or a 0 0 those are super easy to play
and you can play it most people play it
with these ups your fingers because
they're the ears now I tend to play it
with these two fingers my middle finger
and my ring finger like so
because I think it makes it slightly
easier to move to the G which I play in
a different way as well so you see how
if most people play with their big three
figures the G chord this way if you want
to go to an E minor next it makes sense
to keep your index finger there and just
pop your middle finger to me
there's our E minor but because I play
my my G chord mainly with on my middle
finger ring finger little finger it
makes sense for me to keep my middle
finger where it is and then just put my
ring finger to beat there's my E minor
ok so the e minor very very important
chord it's called the relative - even
though you've got an E minor and a B
minor they're not as common or or as
important the E minor is the relative
minor it's it's the most frequent one
another common version of the E minor
that you hear is the E minor 7 which is
adding you're generally your little
finger here on the third fret so you're
going to play 0 2 2 0 3
that's an E - seven okay and on one last
version of the e by not just like with
the C this is our regular way of play C
oh that's my regular way of playing C
okay and I showed you this other way of
playing the C which used all four for
use and it was nice because I can move
from the gym to the C really easily
okay well the same way I can move to the
a minor also quite easily having those
two fingers there and leaving these two
fingers here okay so you'll often see
some guitarists leaving here refigure a
little finger there almost the entire
song because the chords they're using
keep that key that sound there so
there's a band Oasis which is very
famous for I'm playing on one of their
songs and just leaving those those
fingers there so now there's some guy
like I kind of it's call but he goes
yeah okay so they play almost all of
their chords for that song with those
reverse your visa in court
we burn up G
now what is this this is sort of like an
area see there's the a base there and
you've got a lot of lot of other chords
which are in common notes which and come
with a minor key it's not quite an E
minor
it's sort of like an a7 when is it aged
7sus4 again name's not important but you
can play that E minor it's very very
common
okay all right now those are basically
the most important chords that you lead
those six it's almost all of them with a
few variations for the key of G okay but
the out of the six chords the a minor
and the B minor
don't come up nearly as often okay in
common sort of western pop music and you
often hear the same four chords played
over and over again namely number one G
under before C number five and number
six okay so you can call that one four
five and six so people have done this in
the past you know using those four
chords you can put out a lot of
different songs
even so using them over and over again
hence the four chord song okay so if
you've mastered those G C you'll be able
to play a lot of songs okay
and even though you know you're like oh
it's only single K a lot of music is
written in this key but they use a capo
to change it up just a little bit so for
instance if I put the capo on on the
second fret okay and I play all of the
same shapes because they're all high now
what I'm really playing is all of my
chords up to semitones so this is not
really even though it's a G shape it's
actually an a major and this is a
c-shape that's actually a d this is a
deep shame but it's actually E major and
this is an E minor shape it's actually
an F sharp minor so now I'm playing in
the key of a okay so that gives you a
lot of variations we'll talk a bit more
about Capo's and the ways you can change
keys later but I better teach you a song
that you can play in this key now that
you know all these chords okay so I'm
going to teach you the simplest salt I
know in fact it doesn't even use it
doesn't use six chords doesn't even use
the four major chords sort of not major
thus the four important chords common
core's it just uses three and the song
is happy birthday so how do you play all
you need to do is the G the C and the D
okay so I'll play it for you then I'll
walk you through it so it goes
happy birthday okay how'd it go so you
go from the G to the D bend the D back
to the G from the G to C and then very
very quickly you go G someone's party
next time okay
it'll later video I might show you how
to play some other songs in the key of G
but well done you've now worked out how
to play your first key on the guitar